con un plan diseñado para provocar miedo
en los manifestantes así describe la
organización human right watch el
extendido uso de arrestos arbitrarios y
desapariciones forzosas por parte de la
junta militar de mianmar desde el golpe
de estado del pasado primero de febrero
según un informe de la ong las
autoridades han detenido a políticos
periodistas y manifestantes y se han
negado a confirmar su ubicación o
permitir el acceso a abogados o
familiares en violación del derecho
internacional sin órdenes de arresto y
en camiones militares han llegado a
sacar a la fuerza a muchas personas de
sus casas y trabajos burlando cualquier
respeto por los derechos humanos según
el derecho internacional de los derechos
humanos un estado comete una
desaparición forzada cuando las
autoridades gubernamentales o sus
agentes arrestan o detienen a una
persona seguida de una negativa a
reconocer la privación de libertad o de
ocultar la suerte o el paradero de la
persona colocándola fuera de la
protección de la ley la ong asegura que
al no conocerse el paradero de los
desaparecidos la junta está cometiendo
crímenes de lesa humanidad el informe
llega luego de las declaraciones del
consejo de seguridad de la onu
de la crisis en mianmar miembros del
consejo de seguridad expresaron su
profunda preocupación por la situación
que se deteriora rápidamente y condenan
enérgicamente el uso de la violencia
contra manifestantes pacíficos y las
muertes de centenares de civiles
incluidos mujeres y niños la junta
militar no responde ante las acusaciones
internacionales ni tampoco a las
peticiones de los familiares de los
desaparecidos dejándolos con la
incertidumbre de no saber si sus seres
queridos están vivos o muertos la
comunidad internacional ha tratado de
frenar las acciones de la junta con la
imposición de sanciones pero esto
tampoco ha servido para que los que
asumen el poder respondan por la
privación de la libertad de sus
ciudadanos